Take one.
I'm making this film because
I saw myself in your story.
I just felt like I didn't
fit in with my family.
My parents ran this
very controlling house.
I ran away a lot.
Skateboarding was more
a family than my family.
How did you get disciplined?
Well, they call it
child abuse now, but.
Life might be moving too fast.
We have to fully grow
up and it's gonna suck.
When you're a kid, you just do.
You just act.
And then somewhere along the
line, everyone loses that.
I knew you had some
huge weight on you.
Skateboarding meant more to you.
It was kind of a
life-or-death thing.
I remember that screaming
coming from your room,
and it was, like,
really, really unnerving.
One of the last things I said
to my dad was, I hate you.
You can't just have a
child and abandon them.
Life doesn't work like that.
I just don't want him
to grow up like me.
I just want to hide.
I just want to run away.
That's what the
drinking is about.
Maybe you're right.
Maybe I need to just move on.
I could seriously
be on the verge
of having a mental breakdown.
But as long as I'm able to go
skate, I'm completely fine.